mais on commence au site avec une
information importante aussi vous avez
réservé ou gagner votre place sur notre
antenne pour le concert de salif keita
ce samedi au prisme d'elancourt
la date a été annulée en raison d'un
problème de santé de l'artiste
il a été hospitalisé il ya deux jours la
date devrait être reportée au mois de
mai on écoute un mot de la salle danton
pas à mener donc le confrère de plein
fouet l'ensemble de la tournée prévu sur
le mois de janvier pour deux raisons de
santé là nous attendons d'avoir de
connaître la possibilité de report est
dit que nous en serons plus nous voir
mais d'après nos spectateurs pour leur
propre ville d'ath
il fait date leur expliquer les
modalités des changes de celui
[Musique]